to
you
know
for
e
oh yeah
sure
reion
find
I'm very good how about you thank you so
much for coming
this
so
yeah
for
got tomorrow
okay
have
do
that
where oh
okay
than
I think we should get started um has he
got his computer
yet
it is it is almost in the building and
the tech is willing to swap it out as
soon as you need so we're
good
okay
fun
spe
good afternoon everyone welcome to Yale
University my name is Peter salave I'm
the president of the University it's a
great pleasure of mine to be able to
welcome all of you to campus for the
2014 Gruber cosmology prize I welcome
you as y's president uh but also as the
chair of the board of the guber
foundation on which I have served since
2011 uh that was the year that the
foundation was established here at
Yale uh in just a few years the grer
foundation has integrated uh with the
university in ways that further further
emphasize uh Excellence Excellence of
both
institutions
and for several years have led up to
this moment this moment being the first
time we've been able to award grber
prizes here in New Haven at Yale
University the planets have aligned
so tomorrow in conjunction with the
prize event uh the foundation and our
Departments of astronomy and physics uh
will host a conference on cosmology
capitalizing on the presence of so many
of you here today uh we couldn't be more
delighted with this
collaboration and with the mutual
benefits it brings and with the
opportunity to recognize some of the
most distinguished people uh in the
world today working in this field I now
want to present to you the co-founder
and president ameritus of the guber
foundation Patricia guber who will say a
bit more about the prize and about the
foundation
Pat thank you thank you for the warm
welcome and welcome to the 15th annual
cosmology prize honoring a leading
cosmologist astronomer as astrophysicist
or scientific philosopher for
theoretical analytical or conceptual
discoveries leading to fundamental
advances in the
field we thank president salave for the
warm welcome and the warm intellectual
Embrace that Yale has given us we are
home at Yale where the guber prizes have
been administrated since 2011 but as
president salow pointed out this is the
first time we have award awarded a prize
here at Yale and it's fitting because
cosmology was the first prize we ever
awarded so it's a nice uh
parallel my husband Peter and I thought
long and hard about our philanthropic
goals and by partnering with this
distinguished University a structure in
place for more than 300 years which
ensures the science prizes will continue
in the same format including the young
investigator of Awards with our partner
institutions like the international
astronomical Union we have ensured our
mission in addition Yale Awards
approximately 50 Gruber science
fellowships in The Graduate School not
only are we delighted with the science
partnership but we are also gratified by
the human rights programs carried out at
the law school that also continue the
foundation's fundamental missions the
cosmology prize was established in 2000
the first of our International prizes in
conjunction with the international
astronomical Union I'd like to now
introduce Terry
Mel who is the Pres who is the Secretary
General of the
IU and he will describe a little bit
about our long and productive
Association
Terry thank you very much Patricia it is
my great pleasure and privilege to be
here at Y and to present briefly uh a
most recent achievement of the
collaboration between the IU and the
grou of foundation uh the this
collaboration rest on two pillars I
would say one resting with established
science and our distinguished senior uh
astrophysicist who are going to receive
the the the prize today but I'm more
concerned in a way by the younger
generation
and that is by the uh the award of the
fellowship to to Young astrophysicist we
were very fortunate this year to have a
competitive a very high level
competition between Bri right scientists
from many countries and our Laurette is
L lja Lal yes she's here and she's from
Algeria and already has something of a
career she went to France in Strasburg
for her undergraduate studies then moved
to Belgium in lven for her PhD then
started her first postdoc in Denver USA
and the the Gruber Foundation Award
allowed her to go to Chile actually
she's with us today jazia and she's
coming please wait stand up stand
up so she came uh to Chile with the help
of the foundation of the IU and I want
to mention also that we are very
fortunate to have another recipient of
the of the award of the past year Dr Ken
Shen from Taiwan who is now in Santa
Cruz so by all means the the
collaboration between the IU and the
grba foundation is extremely fruitful
now we're we're really looking at very
bright young astrophysicist this who
perhaps may have the cosmology prize one
day or some rather similar prices in the
future and so my my greatest thanks go
to the grobu foundation for this
collaboration and I hope I will be able
to welcome you all next year for the IU
General Assembly that is taking place in
Honolulu and as you know the tradition
is that the cosmology price is handed
over in during the J and so uh I hope to
welcome you there thank you very
much
thank you Terry and unending thanks to
the IU and the long collaboration the
IOU nominates members of our judging
panel which not only ensures the
scientific Integrity of the prize but it
also brings gender and Geographic
diversity to the panel I would like to
acknowledge the vision and Leadership of
my husband Peter Gruber who has been a
spark of inspiration and generosity in
in in establishing all the grber prizes
being Jewish Peter and his family fled
their native Hungary for India during
World War II when the Japanese bombed
Kolkata the family sent the children to
Safety in the Himalayas where they
studied at a Jesuit
school there Peter would help Father
Darcy in the garden and as a reward
would get to look through father Darcy's
telescope it was this experience in part
that led to an award in
cosmology while Peter's Health doesn't
allow us to be doesn't allow him to be
here with us today he sends his warmest
congratulations to all of today's
recipients his quote about cosmology was
it it is the most scientifically
rigorous aesthetically elegant and
poetic of the
Sciences we are here today to honor the
achievements of yan AO Kenneth Freedom
Kenneth Freeman Brent Tully and In
Absentia Sydney Vandenberg whose son
Peter will receive the prize on his
behalf they pioneered the field
nearfield cosmology by establishing a
connection between observations of the
nearby Universe with the Universe on the
whole it is our pleasure to add them to
the list of cosmology
laurates the foundations prize program
which was established in 2000 currently
presents three annual $500,000 prizes in
the fields of cosmology genetics and
Neuroscience each prize recognizes
achievements and discoveries that
produce fundamental shifts in human
knowledge and
culture on October 19th at the 64th
annual meeting of the American Society
of human genetics in San Diego the
genetics prize will be presented to
Victor Ambrose David Balcom and Gary
Roven
in November the Neuroscience prize will
be presented at the 44th annual meeting
of the society for Neuroscience in
Washington DC to Tom Jessel returning to
cosmology we are proud of an illustrious
laurate roster and delighted to be
adding these distinguished members today
the 2014 prize recipients were chosen by
a distinguished Advisory
Board all of us at the foundation
appreciate the knowledge the commit
commitment and the
enthusiasm that these advisers bring to
the judging process we also thank the IU
who nominates members to this board I
would like to now introduce Owen
Gingrich of Harvard University a special
adviser to the prize who will read the
prize
citation it's my honor to read read the
official citation which was put together
by the members of the selection
committee the guber foundation proudly
presents the
2014 cosmology prize to
Yan anasto Kenneth Freeman Brent Tully
Sydney Vandenberg for their pioneering
contributions to the understanding of
the structure and composition of the
nearby
Universe their work laid the foundations
of nearfield
cosmology they clarified the properties
of nearby galaxies dwarfs Spirals
lenticulars and ellipticals through
studies of their morphology stellar and
gaseous content the early recognition of
the role of dark matter and of the
filamentary clustering of galaxies
together with setting the distance scale
of galaxies was crucial in setting the
cosmological context for our current
understanding of the evolution of
galaxies and large scale
structure thank you Owen Owen earlier
today gave us a tour of very important
books in the biniki library here at
Yale it is my great honor to present
sadori okamura of Jose University a
voting member of the selection Advisory
Board to the prize and he will make
remarks about the recipients work today
thank
you it is my great honor uh to speak in
celebration of four exceptional
astronomers
yasto kenis
Freeman Bren and syy
venar recipients of the groove applies
2014 in
cosmology they have worked almost
independently of one another in
relatively nearby galaxies including our
Milky Way
galaxy however their work collectively
late the foundation of nearfield
cosmology one of the two alternative
approaches in
cosmology yasto has been at to
Observatory
Estonia he pointed out in
1974 that giant Galaxies have massive
and extended
Coronas of Unknown
Origin this is an important early
recognition of dark matter in the
universe he was also a Pioneer in the
study of large scale distribution of
galaxies now called The Cosmic web based
on both computer models and
observation leading to his early finding
that dark matter uh plays a Cru crucial
role in the development of cosmic
webs kenis Freeman made a pioneering
study of diss of spiral and rular
galaxies in
1970 pointing out the need for dark
matter to account for the Dynamics of
Galaxy
discs in recent years together with his
colleague brand hon he founded a field
known as Galactic
archaeology where fil evidence is
searched for in order to associate
individual St
populations with their B
places in the Pro Galactic
clowd
Brent has been doing a lifelong
exploration of the threedimensional
structure and dynamics of the nearby
Universe in
1988 together with his colleague Richard
Fisher he mapped
20400 nearby
galaxies to publish the nearby galaxies
catalog along with the uh nearby
Galaxy's
Atlas this is the first major
attempt to illustrate the
threedimensional distribution of
galaxies since then T has been comparing
ever larger and more uh detailed
databases of Galaxy
distances he also made a large
contribution to cosmological distance
scale by the discovery of uh talish IAL
relation syy venberg has been studying
our galaxy and nearby
galaxies searching for clues about their
formation and
evolution since more than a half of a
century
ago his research interests are very wide
including uh variable studs star
clusters super noi and supera lants
local Group D galaxies clusters of
galaxies and morphological
classification of
galaxies sidy spent much of his career
at the University of
Toronto and the Dominion astrophysical
Observatory and his Landmark
contributions are in short
and Lucid papers that
have usually uh single or few
authors Sydney has
been inspirational to many now prominent
astronomers the vision these four
astronomers collectively seek
is
to study the Universe on the largest
scale thinks
small to Y Ken Brent and
sidony I offer
congratulations on behalf of the
entire selection advisory committee
consisting of Andre Fabian Wendy
Freedman ghard huskin her CRA s Saka and
Rashid and two nonbing members oen
gingerich and Martin
re it was a
unanimous agreement of the committee
that the prize be shared amongst the
four four of
you it is my sincere pleasure to be here
in this
ceremony I have been familiar with your
work uh since I was a graduate
student I wish you all a most enjoyable
ceremony s from Far thank
you okay now uh yeah young K
Freeman V and for his father uh Peter
venur please come forward to receive the
prize
okay
all
spe
my thank goes first to patri IA and
Peter grber who started the foundation
and created the cosmology priz a price
of the science which he called the most
emotional I agree with
this uh my price goes also to my
collaborators in tarto actually it's a
long story starting from Eric K mean and
my students and their students and I
thank all of
them uh our study would be impossible
without collaboration with other centers
first of all uh zovic group in Moscow
and the representative of yakob bariso
Rashid is
here also it would be impossible without
observational data and most important
way data from Harvard uh University also
Harvard representative is here and very
close um uh collaboration the
discussions were also with Princeton
people Cambridge and many other centers
I thank all of them and finally I thank
my family uh support for my family was
very important thank
you
patri grba and president salv and
distinguished guests I'm greatly honored
to be sharing the 2014 gruba cosmology
prize with uh my three colleagues thank
you Wendy fredman called me in the
middle of the night when I was observing
on the mountain top to tell me the news
we had a terrible line I could hardly
hear what she was saying I was rather
stunned because because of course I had
no idea that I had been nominated I was
very delighted of course to receive the
award but I have to say that I was even
more delighted to be sharing it with Yan
Brent and Sydney I've known these guys
for decades I've admired their work and
it makes me really happy to be
associated with these three Fells in
this way I'm very sorry that Sydney
can't be with us today and I wish him
all the best on this
occasion
well since since Ken told about how he
was uh told about the prize I'll have to
say how I was appraised to the
prize it was 4 o'clock in the morning
and I was totally
asleep and the phone
rang
and there was a gentleman on the phone
who said that Wendy fredman wants to
talk to me and I said do you know what
time it is it's 4 in the
morning can't she can't this wait till
the morning and I hung
up a few minutes later the phone rang
again and this gentleman said Wendy
breedy thinks you'd like she you'd like
to talk to her it's good
news all right put her
on so that's R to say that this was
totally
unexpected and uh uh as our as my
esteemed colleagues have said it's uh
there are many people involved in in the
whole process of of this I I spend uh
90% of my time I think in my life uh
alone and uh
it's maybe because of that that
opportunity for reflection and being
alone that I I can owe some of my uh
success the last uh little while has
been quite amazing to me because two
weeks ago I I got the art simium prize I
was in Armenia and I uh was uh presented
this by the president of Armenia uh I've
also just in the last weeks had this
whole event with the Lona super cluster
I'll show you a little bit about that in
in the following but uh this has been
quite a different aspect of my life and
I must say that uh it's opened doors
opened uh presented opportunities and
it's been quite wonderful and I thank
you
all Dr okamura told you that my father's
been working in this field for half a
century but his life as an astronomer
really began as a small child they tried
to take a stick and couldn't hit the
moon when he was 5 years old his
grandmother bought him a
telescope and he's since that day I
think he's always known what he wanted
to do and he's been lucky enough to be
able to do it and uh he's loved being uh
part of the community of
astronomers uh he's very grateful to the
uh foundation and for the people who
chose him for this award and he's sorry
he can't be here I'm glad I could be
here to accept the award on his
behalf my
computer
see
yeah need you need
sound
de
Patricia
uh uh Rector uh of the University dear
friends in this short talk I would like
to speak a little bit uh on my own way
to uh to this nearfield
cosmology when I started then uh it
seems that everything is is more or less
clear and uh uh we have a very beautiful
picture of the of
the of the universe only a few little
things where which people didn't
understand and one of these
was comma cluster Mass Paradox and
Galaxy rotation curves but for some
reason this this observation uh
didn't understood by astronomist and so
they were just ignored when I started my
work in uh
in early 50s uh I continued to work by
by and
Kine studying Stellar populations
and uh
building models of galaxies constructing
models of galaxies and then I understood
that it is possible to join these two
aspects that that is to have in models
not only the general Mass distribution
but also uh distribution of individual
populations uh and this uh this was
actually my first step towards this what
we call now
uh nearfield cosmology I understood that
in nearby galaxies where the populations
can be seen individually it is U
possible to to to understand galaxies as
such
uh and it was uh it was
a long way first I uh tried this in our
galaxy then andretta Galaxy then local
group galaxies most difficult problem
was to find mus Luminosity ratios for
individual populations and in in order
to do this it was necessary to build a
uh Evolution model of populations and
then I found that it is impossible to
represent
galaxies by by n Stellar populations
something is still
over and uh the only way to go go out of
this this difficulty is to assume that
there exist a completely new population
what we called Corona because it is not
Halo Halo is old old metal pool stars
and the Halo must be quite large
but
unfortunately using only population data
Galaxy data it was impossible to find
the total mass and radius and the next
step was uh the idea was to use
satellite galaxies as M uh test
particles and the result was U I
reported this in January in Winter
School in h that practically all
Galaxies have giant uh Coronas and the
mass and radius is roughly 10 times
larger than the mass and radius of all
visible populations taken together and
second result was that the total density
of of matter including these dark
Coronas is roughly 20% of critical
density much much more than than assumed
before just after after my my talk
zeldovich invited me to his room and
asked me two
questions uh can we say something on the
nature of dark matter and uh can we uh
find some evidence which can make
difference between
different scenarios of of Galaxy
formation immediately we I had no
answers but uh then uh together with
with our College we we had in in next
year in January a conference in talin on
dark matter and in summer in pissi where
the most important question is what is
the nature of dark matter and the result
was that no known uh population
U can be used to explain it every
population has his his his difficulties
as problem uh High Velocity Stars uh uh
are not not observed neutral gas is
observed but it's only flat in the
galactic dis hot gas is observed in
clusters but the mass is insufficient
roughly factor of
10 smaller even neutrinos were
considered but then zovich students very
quickly realized that from ninos we can
make Coronas of of
clusters they have masses 10 to 15 but
galaxies also have Coronas and the
masses of galaxies this Coronas is 10 to
12 thousand times different so no no
known uh how to say uh particle
or could could be used
and then In Piss there was a discussion
and and gusta tman gusta Andreas
tman told one very strong strong
argument against because primordial
nuclear synthesis predicts that the
total density can be only roughly 5% of
critical density and together with dark
matter we had about 20% it's it's a
large difference that means means in in
framework of
classical U uh uh cosmology Paradigm
dark matter is
impossible and if it is this means that
the classical Paradigm must be changed
and this happened roughly 10 years later
when the cold Dark Matter hyp hypothesis
was
suggested now to the second u z
question uh initially we had no idea how
to answer but then I remembered the our
uh uh previous result of the study of
Stellar population Stellar populations
evolve very slowly very slowly and they
have memory and if uh if galaxies uh uh
no if Gala we knew that Galaxies have uh
uh random motions of the order of
say 100 kilom or second or so that means
during the whole H time they can move
from the uh say point of origin only
roughly one one meapar this order that
means if there are large larger
structure they have memory they remember
what happened uh before and this is seen
here in the right picture it is a um
preprint of our uh paper together with z
uh giant voids in the universe an
eyewitness story of Galaxy
formation this was our second step uh
towards the what we call now nearfield
cosmology we understood that large scale
structure remembers how it it was formed
this means that we needed uh information
not only on small areas on sky but over
the whole sky and then we started
collect data using galaxies clusters
most Vicky able then active galaxies
and put this all together and this was
discussed oh yeah this is the second
scenario uh Jim do you remember your
your face it was in tan conference
77 and uh this uh scenario is slightly
different uh so initially we thought
that there is a fight between two two
scenarios but that it was not uh first
picture uh of the structure
threedimensional structure in talin was
shown by Brent who is now here it is a
local super cluster and it has
filamentary structure and in between
this filaments it is nothing
empty uh some other people did discussed
other superclusters in our study we
considered the whole Northern Hemisphere
and we see here the several
superclusters they have filamentary
structure they are joined by small
Galaxy filaments and and in between is
also it is empty and uh this uh what we
call it now it is Cosmic web at this
time we called it just super was the
white white
Network and uh quite soon it was
understood that properties of this this
network or this web they depend uh on on
properties of dark matter because dark
matter is just a dominant population in
the in the
universe initial initial assumption was
that they are neutrinos but the this
difficulty I already mentioned was very
serious and then cold Dark Matter was uh
suggested and to the end actually the
end result was that both previous
scenario ELO which pancake and people's
hierarchical clustering both are in work
only in different regime first gas
collapses to pancakes or or filaments
and later clustering start so both were
right and what what I like in this
new modern cosmological Paradigm is is a
beauty actually the world is much richer
than thought
before
uh uh it it contains a new population uh
we we were not a far of not say 50 years
ago and second the structure is of the
universe is much more interesting not
just random clustering random random uh
no distribution but it has structure and
from this structure we can learn a
lot uh to end my my short talk I would
like to say that the formation of This
Modern cosmological Paradigm is it's a
work of many many astronomist in in
different centers so it it uh it it is
not a single single Discovery it's a lot
of sequence of of small steps and um I
think most of previous and and present
uh Koba price laats have taken part of
this
do you have
audio
well it's a great pleasure to be here to
to give this short talk this one is
about using chemical techniques to learn
about the evolution of the Galaxy and
it's something that's actually happening
um happening right
now so chemical techniques the
um what we use is the element abundances
in stars and most of the chemical
elements I think you probably know are
actually synthesized in stars and when
the stars died some of the elements are
returned to the interstellar gas so the
element abundances in in the
interstellar gas are increased and
successive generations of star formation
go on and we're probably up to about a
thousand generations of star formation
all the time the chemical properties of
gas are evolving so the stars form from
this gas and the chemical composition at
the surface of a star now reflects the
composition of the gas from which the
star formed and once a star has formed
although its interior composition is
changing all the time because of nuclear
um nuclear reactions its surface
composition which is what we see does
not change significantly as the star
ages except for some of the elements
lighter than
magnesium the light of a star contains a
lot of information about its chemical
composition so what we do to measure
this we pass the staright from the
telescope through a spectrograph that
disperses the light the dispersed light
is what we call the telescope spectrum
and it contains vast numbers of dark
bands produced by the different chemical
elements and from these Spectra we can
measure the abundances of 30 or more of
the chemical elements at the surfaces of
the star and what I'm going to show you
now is just a very small piece of the
blue spectrum of the sun just to show
you how much information is actually
there so this is just a little piece of
17 angstrom a tiny little piece of blue
light and every one of these dips that
you can see in it is due to some
chemical element some of them like iron
are very strong others are much much
weaker and I've listed here A whole
bunch of the elements I won't read them
all out which are actually represented
in this tiny piece of spectrum so just
from the light of a star there's this
enormous amount of information that we
can glean now the Stars themselves
they're actually born in Star clusters
you rarely get stars born on their own
they're typically born in clusters of a
thousand to about a million stars in
almost all of the Star clusters the ones
that are surviving the chemical
properties of the stars in the cluster
are almost identical over almost all of
the elements there is identical as we
are able to measure so you have a
cluster of stars like this every Star is
chemically the same and what that says
is that the gas from which these
clusters form is very well
homogenized the abundances of star
clusters are different as you go from
one cluster to another cluster and that
just just depends on the chemical
properties of the gas from which they
formed but most of these um star
clusters don't live very long after
about 20 million years they lose mass as
their Stars age and the cluster disrup
disrupts it doesn't disrupt violently it
just gradually drifts apart the stars
are no longer bound together and the
stars of a cluster are spread right
around the Galaxy but the Stars remember
their chemical composition as they dis
around the Galaxy and if we can find
stars in the galaxy with identical
compositions over 25 or 30 chemical
elements then they are probably part of
the debris of one common disrupted star
cluster and in this sense these debris
stars are the fossil remnants of the
disrupted cluster and this whole area of
of work which I I'll I'll talk about
just for for a couple of minutes this
has come to be known as Galactic
archaeology it probably should be called
Galactic paleontology because of the
fossil nature of it but we're using
these Remnant fossils to try and Trace
the evolution of the Galaxy formation of
the star clusters is a a major part of
the Assembly of a Galaxy what I mean by
assembly is the whole process of turning
gas into stars and building up the
galaxies that we see the whole process
is pretty poorly understood most of what
we know about Galaxy formation actually
doesn't come so much from observation it
comes from computer simulations
we would like to find an observational
way to determine the history of the
Assembly of the
Galaxy another thing that contributes to
the building up of the Galaxy is small
galaxies that drop into ours and
gradually contribute a certain amount of
mass now using chemical methods we can
also find the fossil remnants of the
disrupted clusters and the small
galaxies which help to build up the
Milky Way and in this way we can
determine observationally the history of
Galactic of the Assembly of the Galaxy
and this technique is called chemical
tagging chemical tagging to do this it's
a it's a big job it requires high
resolution Spectra not quite as smart as
the ones I showed you but they're
comparable of about a million stars they
have to be homogeneously observed they
have to be homogeneously analyzed and
this is the prime science driver for a
new instrument that I'm going to tell
you about in just a moment so summary so
far just to to summarize what I've I've
been trying to say star clusters are the
main way in which stars form and build
up the dis of our galaxy The Star
clusters individually are chemically
homogeneous most of these clusters don't
live for long after 10 or 20 million
years they disrupt and the stars are
spread right around the galactic dis but
we can identify the debris of these
ancient disrupted star clusters using
chemical techniques and then measure
their ages and in this way we can
determine the history of the Assembly of
the galactic dis so just a little bit of
notation for for for what's coming we
use a bracket
notation um we use iron as the typical
heavy element because there's so much of
it and we give its abundance relative to
hydrogen and we use this bracket
notation Fe overh it just means the
abundance of hydrogen of of iron
relative to hydrogen if it's zero it
means it's the same as the sun it's a
logarithmic scale so it's minus one the
iron hydrogen is a tenth of the sun if
it's minus 2 that means it's 100th of
the Sun so the abundance of the other
elements things like titanium for
example a given relative to iron so
titanium to iron in Brackets equal zero
means that the titanium to iron ratio is
the same as it is in the sun it's just a
notation we've used for donkey years so
the galactic disc I'm just going to tell
you a tiny bit about the parts of the
Galaxy and how they fit into what we're
trying to do so here's the a picture of
our our own Galaxy taken from near near
Earth in the infrared and you can see
the dominant structure is this dis the
dis is the major Stellar component of
galaxies like the Milky Way and in the
case of our galaxy the mass is about
four the mass of stars is about 4X 10 to
the^ 10 solar masses as we go out from
the center we find that the mean element
abundance the iron abundance for example
drops gradually as we go out and the
other interesting thing is so if we look
at some place like here which is roughly
where where we would be there's a wide
range of Stellar abundances of the given
radius and age and we don't understand
that let me just show you what I mean
this picture here just shows you radius
in the Galaxy against the iron abundance
and it's the average for a a class of
young Stars called seids they're very
good traces the sun I can't quite see
where where the sun is but I think the
sun is about here so it should be pretty
much zero Where We Are and you can see
how as we go out in radius in the Galaxy
the abundance drops now we are sitting
more or less where this red circle is
and what this picture shows you is how
the iron abundance is distributed for
stars of different ages and let's look
at so middle-aged stars stars that are
about 5 billion years old the errors of
measurement here are actually quite
small and you see there's this very
large spread in chemical properties for
stars of middle age and these are all
stars near the sun in that sort of red
circle you see there almost a Whole
Decade of difference here so this is a
about a third of the solar abundance
this is up around three times the solar
abundance now the big puzzle that we
we're coming to trying to come to groups
with now where do these stars that are
so metal rich near the sun where do they
come
from stars are not being made young
stars now are not as metal rich as as as
these ones and the belief is that these
stars have migrated out into the solar
area from this metal Rich part of the uh
Galactic just right in here the process
we don't understand very well it's
called radial migration it's a big issue
in Galactic archaeology now we don't
know how important it is I can tell I
can tell you that we this is something
we can measure how important it is using
chemical T tagging techniques I can't go
into the details there's another
component I want to mention that's also
part of our archaeological um prise here
is another disc component here's a
picture of a galaxy and you can see the
thin dis now this is the same galaxy the
same picture but just the difference s
of the stretch and you can see that the
disc has now gotten a lot thicker in in
this direction and that's the thick disc
most of you can't see this thick disc
now we've got one of these in our own
Galaxy and these again are stars near
the sun these Stars here belong to the
thick disc and these ones belong to the
thin dis this is there Iron abundance so
these are stars like the sun these are
starss like the tenth of the Sun but the
interesting thing is when you look at
the abundance of other elements relative
to iron we see that particularly a class
of elements called Alpha elements are
much richer in this thick disc than they
are in this thin disc now the we don't
properly understand how the thick disc
formed yet but what we do know is if you
see a large amount of titanium relative
to iron it means that most of this
chemical enrichment occurred by very
massive stars when they explode and die
whereas if you see more iron that occurs
when lower Mass stars um die so what
what this is telling us when we see all
this titanium in the thick dis it's
telling us that the thick disc is a it
tells us that it's very old and the
other thing it tells us the stars formed
very rapidly and the whole chemical
Evolution was over before a lot of these
low mass stars had time to explode Lo so
this is all all very interesting for us
when we're doing this Galactic
archaeology it's going to be a very
interesting component for chemical
tagging it's old it's Alpha enhanced and
it may have formed for example through
the disillusion of giant clumps in the
early Galaxy that we see now in forming
this high red shift so now we're
connecting back to the farfield
cosmology and what I'm talking about
here is an image of a galaxy comes from
the gendel group it's a Galaxy the red
shift of
2.2 it's dominated by these huge clumps
these huge star forming clumps these
green ones are are still forming very
massive stars these red ones have
stopped forming very massive stars but
these are enormous structures they're
almost Galaxy size things in themselves
they have um huge star formation rates
20 solar masses a year um enormous
masses 10 9 solar masses remember our
own Galaxy the Stellar mass is only 4X
10 10 so so if these CL these clumps are
believed not to last very long again
they just um basically evaporate um and
if these clumps in the end form the
thick disc as as various people have
suggested then it means that the thick
disc would have formed from a relatively
small number of these huge clumps if
that's the case that's going to be very
easy for us to tell using these chemical
tagging techniques so a major goal of
the whole chemical tagging process is to
try and identify how important merges
and accretion events were relative to
just the quent formation of star
clusters the cold dark matter
simulations that that Yan mentioned um
they predict a high level of merger
activity and that conflicts with some of
the observed uh properties of uh of this
galaxies so using chemical T tagging
techniques we try to find the debris of
groups of stars that are now spread
right around the Galaxy that were
associated with birth either because
they were they were born together in a
single Galactic star formation event
like a cluster or because they came from
a common ACC created Galaxy that fell in
so I'm just going to close with a few
words about this this new instrument
that we've built to do this it's called
Hermes it's a high resolution fiber fed
multiobject spectrometer on the 4 meter
telescope in Australia and its
particular thing is that we can acquire
Spectra of about 400 stars at once and
that makes it possible to do an enormous
survey involving a million stars the
spectral resolution if you're into the
stuff is is high and that's high enough
to do this sort of chemical study and
the main driver of building this thing
was to do what a survey called the galar
survey if you've been in Australia you
know galar is a pink a pink and gray
bird but galar just means Galactic
archaeology with Hermes so chem chemical
tagging is is the real driver here so we
started using this instrument um on the
a to measure the chemical properties of
a million stars we've already done in
fact it's more like 70,000 now and the
goal is to use these chemical tagging
techniques to try and recognize the
debris of disrupted star clusters and
then we'll use those fossils to trace
the assembly history of the of the
Galaxy and I just want to mention one
more thing and that is the Synergy that
a project like this has with a a
wonderful European space mission called
guia guia has been launched several
months ago what guia does it measures
extremely precise positions motions on
the sky and just triangulation parallx
distances guia will measure distances
for all of the stars that we are doing
with the Hermes instrument it'll measure
um distances to um about 2% in the end
if these numbers mean anything to you
these are these are very very very
precise numbers it's one with fact one%
distance errors for most most of our STS
very accurate transverse motions and
what that will let us do in combination
with the chemical work it'll give us
accurate uh transverse velocities for
all the stars in the Hermes sample
accurate distances at a level that we've
never had uh such precise distances
before accurate distances for all of the
survey stars and that'll let us check
that the stars that we chemically tag as
having a common birth uh really do have
the same age so this is what really what
we're doing now in this field of
Galactic archaeology thank
you
right
CH so I don't know where your
power
okay so let's get rid of
that let's
uh get a meeting from right
here bring it
up yes let me go down here and bring it
up
okay you going bring oh you got the
sound in here MH
so I've been uh I was a bad boy here and
came to this uh discussion here uh
forgot to bring my computer so it was
rushed in here at the last
minute so I would like to thank a bunch
of people that some of remembered on
this
here and uh in
particular uh sign out I want remember
Rick fer I wish he was here I should
stand here yeah yeah so Rick fiser
played a well Rick Fisher and I worked
together there um in the early days of
my career um and uh due to health
reasons he wasn't able to come here
today but uh back in 1975 we figured out
a way to measure distances the galaxies
uh
that got our name attached to it uh it's
a simple concept that uh a spiral galaxy
uh with a lot of mass has also a lot of
light uh and so if it's a big Galaxy
with a lot of light and is
brighter um it will also be rotating
faster because of that mass so more mass
rotates faster more light you get a
correlation then between how fast the
Galaxy is rotating big and fast rotating
uh small slow rotating this is what we
saw in
1975 this is uh more recent data that
we've uh
more recent versions that of the very
same plot here where this is how fast
the Galaxy's rotating this is how bright
it is and through this mechanism then if
I go off and look at a random galaxy in
the universe and I see how fast it's
rotating then I know how intrinsically
bright it is and so then I can measure
how bright it seems to be get a distance
so that then is is a way that we got
distances uh to many
galaxies
um I'll just make a comment here that
probably the other people of uh in the
room that are researchers know very well
there's probably a a a poor correlation
between um what others seem to think are
important work and what we think
ourselves are our important work and I I
just really wanted to mention here what
I personally considered to be the the
work that gave me the most pleasure um
and
only it wasn't so recognized by the rest
of the world here because it's this is
uh my this is Citation counts for
various Publications I've had and and so
my paper that I really think was the one
that I really like the best is number 75
in terms of
citations uh that's this paper here uh
and I'm not even the first author Ed
Shay is the first author and he's back
here at the back of the room but I I
learned more uh with this paper that I
ever learned with any other paper that
I've been involved with um and we really
uh anticipated a lot of things in this
paper in
1984 uh there were some things happening
at the same time
uh it was to do with the angular
momentum content of galaxies how
galaxies grow how um when they fall into
clusters there's uh TI locking
mechanisms that have been really
anticipated or or or flushed out more
recently with all the simulations that
are done but but a lot of the the
concepts were here Al also uh Galaxy
starvation when when galaxies fall into
clusters well uh one of the main things
I've been doing in my career is is is
mapping uh the distribution of G well I
should stand back here shouldn't I um
I've been uh mapping galaxies then U
over my career and and just to show you
that really does go a long way back
here's a cartoon that uh Was Made Of Me
by uh a colleague U Back early in my
career uh he caught another uh glimpse
of me here
and so i' I've been doing this uh
mapping quite a bit and it culminated
then in this uh this catalog uh an atlas
of of galaxies in the mid uh 70s and uh
and to this day really is the only um uh
catalog of G atlas of galaxies on paper
now people are going
electronically electronic but uh this is
a paper version and of the distribution
of galaxies
and it's uh gone a little farther now
where uh uh today's version is is uh
this lanaka super cluster uh and I
wanted to just show you then uh a little
movie that would uh then so here this
has a soundtrack on it so I'm going to
actually shut up while this is
playing this came out how many of us a
small blue planet the Third Rock From
the Star called the sun just one of
billions of stars in a spiral galaxy
known as The Milky
Way but where in the universe is the
Milky
Way a team of scientists gather data on
more than 8,000 of the galaxies that
surround
us they maed each Galaxy's position and
movement in
space and for the first time they've
shown that the Milky Way is part of a
much larger of galaxies a supercluster
that they have named
lania the Milky Way is nested in the
furthest reaches of the structure on the
outskirts the entire universe can be
seen as an intricate network of galaxies
a cosmic we some areas are almost empty
dark voids others are densely packed
with galaxies in regions known as
superclusters super clusters are the
biggest structures found in the universe
that scientists have struggled to Define
where one ends and another
begins to M our home Su cluster a team
led by Brent tul at the University of
Hawaii studied the Motions of the
galaxies around us in unprecedented
detail even though the entire universe
is expanding rapidly gravity is also at
work pulling against this
acceleration by discounting Cosmic
expansion the team worked out which
galaxies are being towards us shown in
blue and which are being pulled away
shown in red this enabled them to create
a map of cosmic flows the paths that
galaxies migrate along tugged at a tiny
Pace by the force of
gravity using this motion they came up
with a new way to map the distribution
of matter in the
universe delving into our home super
cluster you can see that most galaxies
are being pulled towards a dense Center
this is known as the great attractor our
galaxy is among those sliding towards
this patch of space which dominates our
region of the
universe let's take a different
view each circle represents the
Galaxy again we can see most galaxies
being pulled towards the great attractor
in the direction of the arrows between
the great attractor and us the Noy way
is a relatively empty area a blue void
and next to us is Virgo a Lar dense
cluster whose bright Galaxies have been
observed from Earth for
centuries until now astronomers group
does the Milky Way in it surrounding
galaxies with Virgo and nearly 100 other
clusters in a super cluster that
stretches 100 million light beavs across
but using this new technique we can see
that this is just a tip of the
iceberg this cluster of clusters is
merely an appendage of a much larger
super cluster more than 100 times bigger
and more massive
but how did the team know how to redraw
the boundaries of this Cosmic
map here's our super cluster in black
and a neighboring structure perus Pisces
in red scientists Define the boundary as
the points where the flows of galaxies
diverge like water dividing into
watershed this is where neighboring
structures Shear
apart this is the first clear definition
of a
supercluster l means IM Heaven in
Hawaiian A fitting name for the vast
community of galaxies that we are a part
of so now we know that on the edge of a
super cluster of L in a galaxy called
the Milky Way Around a star we call the
sun there is a small blue planet our
home so that's had 2 and a half million
hits in the last uh uh in the last few
weeks weeks so I'll just
uh wind up here
oops I think we're just about at a close
and if any of you have questions we're
going to have a reception right away so
I think there will be plenty of
opportunity to talk to our amazing
recipients today
so I want to thank all of our
recipients Professor anasto Freeman and
Tully and congratulations again
congratulations also across the distance
to professor vandenbberg
and thank you president
salave and participants and thanks to
all of you ladies and gentlemen for
joining us here today and this concludes
our program please join us for the
reception thank
you